hello everyone
welcome to rational science
directly from frankfurt germany
i've had the sniffles these days
and uh ons
uh he's been sick for 10 days
he's coming out of it now we thought he
had covered but no he checked himself
and
only a bad cold
anyways what do we do here uh we do
physics primarily and we think we're the
only site on the internet that does
physics
everybody else does math
and irrational explanations why because
they base them on particles and waves
and no one has suggested
anything different than particles or
waves except this site
we say that
light gravity are all mediated by
an electromagnetic rope all atoms in the
universe are physically interconnected
all atoms in your body are connected to
every atom in my body that's what we say
okay that's the assumption with which we
work and we also do a little bit of
extinction here we're saying we're the
last humans on earth or the last
generation of humans on earth we don't
have too long to go okay
and so we start our talk today
like usually
uh we like we usually do uh
with
a little bit subjects matters related to
extinction
okay so uh here's uh one of the
headlines that is of interest lately
which is taiwan you know
and we it says there the us can't fight
china for taiwan but it can help taiwan
make china think twice about starting a
war
you make it expensive you make it uh
cost
ineffective
costs the in lives
and the economy is destroyed that sort
of thing
and this is a lieutenant colonel uh
somewhat prominent in the news lately
defending the notion that the united
states should not go to war
against china to defend taiwan in fact
what he says is
give them weapons yeah but let them take
care of their own security
and if china decides to attack lay off
and he says he's his view is not
accepted very well in
washington uh
looks like everybody is a hawk over
there and they say if china takes taiwan
by force the united states will
intervene militarily
and the question to you is uh
will that be the end of humanity i mean
are they gonna stop at conventional
weapons or are they gonna continue
uh all the way to
nuclear weapons
that's the issue and yeah if there is
gonna be a war sometime in the future
uh you better learn the word taiwan
because i think it's gonna be because of
taiwan forget about the korean war
vietnam war afghanistan war none of that
will matter
if they go head-to-head with china
my my take on that is it's all over okay
and they may not have a choice uh
you know because if if they don't go to
war
then what's going to happen is the
[Music]
chinese are going to
pass them and just keep going
and one way or the other the united
states is going to lose so i think the
united states will be forced to go to
war and create some incident possibly a
um
false flag
something like that
that's very common
okay uh here we have another issue
warehouse jobs recently thought of as
jobs of the future are suddenly jobs few
workers want
everybody's i'm covered everybody's at
home receiving checks and nobody wants
to go to work
and i once uh
suggested that
that situation where you want to solve
the world's problems
or even worse i mean like solve them
like you know when death
gets to you you solved all your problems
that sort of solve problems right you
want to
cause extinction very easy very very
easy all you have to do is give every
person on earth a million dollars
see how easy it was you give everyone on
earth a million dollars and then lots of
people i i would say at least half the
population if not a lot more
will not go to work everybody say oh i'm
going to take a vacation
and there's gonna be no place to have a
vacation because there won't be any
services because everybody's on vacation
and so uh
yeah you want to destroy the world
economy very easy just give everybody a
million dollars which is more or less
what these people are doing they're
creating money you know with a magic
wand
okay and uh here you know we have that
situation they're giving money to people
people stay at home
and a lot of people say well i think i'm
gonna be choosy about the next job i get
and so that says that amazon target
walmart all these uh big corporations
you know they they pledge to create
hundreds of thousands of these positions
at competitive wages and increasingly
with perks like free college etcetera
right
and but the industry is facing an
unexpected problem far too few people
are willing to take on the often
grueling work according to industry
officials and economic data
what do you think of that
yeah
[Music]
a lot of people don't want to work they
want to
make money easy because they see other
people make easy money and uh so
work is going to be a word that they're
going to remove from the dictionary
that's what's going to happen eventually
okay uh we had some issues several guys
here which
apparently have problems with women
catching up or even overtaking now
it challenges their manhood
and so they're they're worried and all i
can say about this is we're in a new age
guys
and some of these comments that you're
going to see here you know shows that
these people are you know
uh floating in on air
uh they're they don't have the feet on
their feet on the ground anymore and
you'll see
it becomes quite obvious okay here we
have one guy says just because one
species isn't equal to another doesn't
magically mean women are or could be
equal to men
yeah i agree uh
you know
i mentioned that uh situation there
where
you put the guy
in a lioness in a uh in the coliseum
right the fight
and
my money is going to be on the
on the lioness and you say how can that
possibly be she's a female and he's a
male
and he might even be bigger than the
lioness uh at least taller for sure
right
well but see she's got skills that this
guy doesn't have she's got velocity
speed he's got a lot of stuff this guy
doesn't have
and so to say that he can really face a
lioness and beat her
i don't know my money's my money's on on
her
okay
and and again i'm not saying that um you
know i use this as an analogy
can women eventually catch up with men
uh in speed in strength
in
things which are traditionally male okay
uh is it that we just kept them behind
you know we kind of squeezed them
and didn't let them rise is that what
the issue was
could it be that now that you know women
are asking for all this equality etc
uh maybe if we give them enough time
right 100 years whatever maybe 200 years
that they come up to speed and they
match
man
one for one in boxing and especially in
the you know the tough sports like
wrestling boxing
um
speed
weight lifting
i mean
is is there something a woman in that
sense cannot do that a man can do
and why would she be relegated behind a
man is it this estrogen testosterone
issue
and a lot of men
today
and a certain way i i understand them
are threatened by this you know their
manhood is being threatened and say they
don't like the fact that women are
catching up first legally
and becoming our equals you know that's
already a problem but if they also
match us in strength and speed and so on
well you know
they've taken our manhood away right
and this is the issue but we live in a
different time
and all i'm saying is
you may have your dreams that are what
should be ideal you know man should be
like this women should be like that
but see we're the last humans on earth
we're the last generation of humans on
earth the last generation is going to
experience something a little different
than all the other generations
and part of that is
this equality this diversity thing
that's coming up okay we're all in the
cities and we don't have this issue of
you know i gotta lift the log i'm gonna
do the hunting you stay at home you take
care of the kitchen
you know uh that air is gone
you know now everybody lives
more or less a bachelor life
uh
even those who get married get divorced
and go on their own ways
no kids fewer kids as time goes by so
we're moving into society where we have
singles
out there
and each one takes care of his own needs
and etc and so they don't really need to
get
together in for a long time like in the
old days
we have a society of singles that's the
society of the service economy
and so that's the point that i'm trying
to make with all this i want you to
notice that something has changed which
is drastically different than what used
to be in the past 19th century all the
way to maybe the 1970s 1980s
we had um
the nuclear
family because we had manufacturing now
we're in the service economy and service
economy is the last stage of man man's
economy and uh
and it's a society where we don't have
any more the nuclear family the nuclear
family will die
gradually and it will give way to
individuals to solitary
bachelors
living in a multitude of bachelors
that's the world that is coming up so
you get a new world now and part of that
is this
equality thing not only legal equality
where women not only vote etc etc but
also
physical equality and you might say well
no they'll never catch up with us well
that the only reason you think like that
is because we've always kept them down
and now they're catching up
and i can't tell you because i i don't
know the future but i can tell you for
one thing they are catching up they're
uh
shrinking the distances between
men and women uh you know the the
records etc and the question is will
they ever catch up
and i don't know i don't know the answer
it's for you to think about okay
anyways here we have uh someone says
some women can compete against the
average man okay as of now they cannot
compete effectively in most strength
sports against athletic men yeah as of
now
okay let's keep that in mind if we
consider two humans born the same day
started training the same day etc
i believe in strength sports men still
have an image yeah today no doubt about
that
not because of testosterone and estrogen
but rather all the genetical factors
within the classification of the male
sex uh yeah it could be the genetic
factors and that could be the limiting
factor for women that's one possibility
uh another possibility is that uh again
uh
the they lag behind
because we've kept them behind and now
they're catching up and the question is
do we have any genetic advantage over
women
are women becoming taller and taller on
the average faster than men are becoming
taller because men are becoming taller
as well but women are also catching up
and maybe they're becoming on the
average
taller faster than men are growing uh in
in tallness in you know
how large they are and so you know i
mean you have women out there that are
seven feet tall even today because women
are also growing
okay so
i don't know will the averages
eventually even out i don't know i can't
tell you but it's something for you to
ponder
uh
other animals you know like gorillas
they they have a big difference between
the gorilla male and the
female gorilla okay it's a dimorphism
extreme dimorphism but among the monkeys
we are the ones with the least
physical dimorphism first and maybe
that's because women have caught up with
us with us men you know they are
becoming our equals in many ways and the
question is will they become equals also
in physical prowess or architecture or
whatever you want to call it
morphology
okay another fellow and here you can see
what these people they're floating in
air okay
you definitely overrate women oh i don't
know i'm not overrated i'm just telling
you the facts
they may get better over a long period
of time but i doubt that as well as if
uh as it would require extreme
conditions and lots of bottlenecks okay
if you're looking comparing of random
men in street fight videos and rondo's
fights you know ronda rousey i talked
about the other day
you'll see that rhonda's superior only
in technique oh just only
yeah a lion is is only superior
technique you know lioness doesn't have
to be stronger in fact than a human male
right uh all she has to do is just beat
you in in speed and she could
you know scratch you
okay you'll see that rhonda's superior
only in technique an average man has
more aggression speed strength size
stronger body structure
and is better suited psychologically for
stressful situations
these people really believe this
you know they think that they can beat
rhonda if they get in the ring with her
and
oh man i would love to see that you know
i would love to go there with my beer
and uh you know a little bag of potato
chips because it's gonna last 10 seconds
the fight
and uh what would i watch well i would
watch this guy being thrown out of the
ring that's what i would want
these guys really think that oh she's a
she's just a little girl
rhonda is not a little girl guys
ronda rousey and all these girls that do
kickboxing and so on they are gladiators
get it through your thick skulls they
are gladiators they're trained uh
fighters
and to say well i'm bigger than her i
weigh 50 pounds more than her well it
just means you're just going to be
slower
or you know the heart the more you weigh
the harder you fall that's all it is
she's going to run circles around you
okay
she'll know when to hit you because
she's already sees these spots you know
you know i did i did uh wrestling when i
was a kid i did karate and uh
and i know a little bit about that okay
i'm not an expert but i do know a little
bit because i like i like to do those
sports and i can tell you you know the i
don't think i want to get in the ring
with
with rhonda especially i don't want to
get into the cage if the fight is to the
finish you know like
to the finish now i'd rather be in the
ring because in that case i i can climb
over the ropes and get out of there
so she doesn't kill me
uh yeah for these guys to believe that
they can really beat run that's they
don't even have their feet on the ground
anymore okay you're really dreaming
fellas you
you're you're watching too much tv and
eating too much popcorn at home go into
the ring and see if you can match
good old little rhonda that little girl
she's gonna mop the floor with you
okay
uh
here we have another comment
says transgender uh male to female we
know they they don't really become real
women since there ain't an alchemical uh
magical component that transmutates a
man into a woman yeah in other words uh
you have you know the xy
uh and the xx chromosomes you cannot
even if a male believes he's a woman or
vice versa and they make this sex change
operation it doesn't mean because of
that he's going to change the
xy in one case the xx in the other right
and that's how you can tell a man from a
woman
today you need to go to that level to
find out who's a man who's a woman you
know and then all this other stuff about
bathrooms and so on that's just politics
okay
but transgenderism is a result of
inbreeding because it is often found out
in people with a lot of mental
psychopatholog pathologies like
autism bpd schizophrenia
dementia body dimorph
the morphe etc yeah
my take on that is that um
this is a an issue that we're having
today um of genetics primarily of
genetics we did inbreeding for so long
and uh still doing it today and in that
sense i think we're at the end of the
line also you know we don't have too
long to go even if the economy did not
destroy us
if the economy did not collapse
i think uh what would we would die in a
um background extinction in other words
our single species even though we would
probably take other animals with us but
we would die for a different reason
altogether which is
uh the overturning of our population
pyramid and the loss of genetic
diversity essentially those two factors
will
uh create the death of our species but
we're fortunate we're not gonna die like
that which is an agonizing death which
is what the
uh neanderthals suffered uh no we're
going to die in a mass extinction
we're going to take all the animals with
us okay we have the power to do that by
the way
okay another fellow says
says countries with greater gender
equality index
uh show greater inequalities okay
between the sexes because when you
neutralize environment you free genetics
and if genetics are different it shows
the differences even more than before
okay so women today because they are
free
actually gravitate more towards
traditionally feminine jobs
rather than the opposite great examples
are norwegian gender equality paradise
and israeli kibbutz uh the only
exceptions are women from restricting
countries like i guess the arab
countries he's referring to going to
freer ones wanting to try out what they
have been kept doing from doing uh
the um
this this fella is uh
referring really to an agricultural
society and he thinks that that's the
way we're going you know it's the other
way around this is what's dying in fact
the co-hoses in
in russia they disappeared already there
are no cohouses there
kibbutz there's still a few out there
but again they're they're kind of like
stimulated by the government for those
people who like to live in communes and
um
and do farming and living you know in
groups and so on uh socialists who have
this idealism in their heads well yeah
they they still have these kibbutz but
the kibbutz life is a farming life and
their woman women had you know you had
division of labor there you cannot say
that in a society where we are all
office workers we're going to have the
same situation it's totally different
you cannot generalize this and
extrapolate it to the city life
okay
and the fellow continues really
he says
says but women born in freer countries
actually become more womenish in their
choices most women and i put their stem
because
this comes out of an article or several
studies that they made out there where
they say that women are not oriented
towards science technology mathematics
and i can't remember what the e was but
uh
equations maybe
but anyways it's saying like women are
not science oriented that's what this
study more or less showed other people
criticized it uh saying that it was not
a very that it had false the study had
false anyways the point here is that
this fellow is using this as an example
says most women today are becoming more
traditionally feminine in their life
decisions in the west and
masculine more most athlete women have
fertility issues intrinsically linked to
physical efforts thus over time this is
not a fit strategy
well you know
really i don't see it this way at all i
see it exactly in the opposite you've
heard of masculinization of women and
feminization of men and it was an
article that i looked up
and
i just
took some
bits and pieces out of it just to give
the main points says some men assert
their manhood by stressing their
heterosexuality
in order to compensate for this
feminization of men this move marks a
clear rejection of homosexuality
seen as the personification of the
feminine man
western society has been moving in the
direction of what greater gender
equality since the feminist revolution
as well as focusing on their careers
women can now be self-sufficient and
strong
so yeah i i agree more with the one on
the right and not with the fellow on the
left okay i think um
we're moving in the opposite direction
to what he's saying there
and that's my take everybody makes his
own assumptions but that's the
uh
that's the assumption i work under okay
i'm saying uh
we're headed
i can't see the wrong direction it's not
a wrong direction it's not an irrational
direction it's just the fact that's the
direction which we're headed okay and so
all i'm saying is you have to meet
reality and try to
you know
absorb it and just take it like it is
you know accept what's out there you
cannot deny what's out there these
people say i can beat ronda rousey
you've got your feet off the ground guy
get down back to earth she can slaughter
you okay she's not a little girl she's a
gladiator
that's what she is
okay we have a couple coveted comments
one person says the vaccines you
referred to are built into
in a different way and are called
perfect because it will protect from
getting a disease so it ends the
transmission chain okay there are leaky
vaccines as well they do not prevent
transmission and cause more dangerous
mutations marriage disease is a
reference you can check
uh i'm not into this stuff at all okay
first of all i'm saying that disease
doesn't cause the extinction of man
that's one issue and then the other one
is that you know i'm not into uh
medicine at all i don't care at all
about medicine and all this stuff uh the
covet the only reason i raised the
subject is i got the shots i got my
second shot a few
couple weeks now and i think i got sick
because of that
but uh i got the shots only because i i
plan to travel and you know i don't want
the hassle that we have out there still
and probably for some time to come
but other than that i don't care about
the cobit because you know it doesn't
affect my life at all you know i was a
year and a half from whatever whenever
it started without paying even attention
to it to the subject matter because i
don't care about it doesn't
doesn't affect me at all but people who
work with lots of people they might be a
little more concerned especially if
they're young you know if you're 20 25
years old and you're working in a place
where you got lots of people
you may be concerned about that you say
well i don't know enough about it to
make a decision i better get the shot
but see in my case i didn't care about
the shot because i don't work with a lot
of people etc you know i do research do
a lot of lonely stuff you know so um
you know it's something that doesn't
affect me it's only when i go out there
and travel that they give me a lot of
hassles and i say no i'm not going to
fight city hall i'm just going to go
with the flow
did i get a poison in there yeah i got
some poison in there does it do any good
i don't know if it did or not i don't
care
it's just a non-issue for me okay
another fellow says on covet he says why
would you care about being forced to
accept experimental gene therapy if you
got a shot as a kid
seriously yeah i said the other day that
you know people get kids get shots when
they go to school elementary school
that's government mandated they they
accept it it's like nobody
uh protests nobody
fights against it or or challenges it
except maybe some religious folk you
know out there
but they got their shots
and now they say oh but i'm not going to
get the covet shot because it's mandated
by the government's experimental and
blah blah blah yeah but all shots are
really experimental you know uh remember
uh
it was in the 50s we had the salk
vaccine for um
uh what was it
polio
and then uh later they had a better
vaccine which was the
saving
and uh so
uh all these vaccines are really uh
experimental and if the bug
evolves you gotta evolve the vaccine to
catch up with it and so they become
experimental as time goes by
so
you know again we're all guinea pigs in
in a sense yeah no doubt about it and
you're taking a risk maybe a lesser risk
i don't know if you take the shot then
if you don't i don't know this is
something that uh i'm not into at all
i don't even research that subject
matter i do research disease only in
reference to population because like
smallpox was the biggest killer in the
history of life uh history of man right
uh it's the one it's probably the
disease that killed the most people in
in
in time you know you heard of the
bubonic plague
it's probably
up there with that first one with
smallpox but i think smallpox was the
big one and once we conquered smallpox
uh we could live longer and so
what happened is our great grandfathers
those that passed smallpox they passed
those good genes to us and smallpox no
longer even if it's out there i don't
think it could cause as much devastation
as it did you know hundreds of years ago
okay as a kid i accepted what
authorities told me okay and so now he's
grown up i guess okay and
that has changed i now know viral
transmission infection has never been
demonstrated okay so he changed his
religion he believes in something else
that's fine i mean nothing wrong with
that uh you don't believe in bugs and uh
antibodies and all that stuff okay uh no
problem but what i'm saying is
you did get a shot before and you say
well i was a kid i had no choice in the
matter my folks told me to get the shot
or the
teachers told me to get the shot or the
government you know and so you had to
accept it and now you say well now i'm
not taking any longer that's fine
again it's uh whichever religion
whichever god you pray to okay
okay
here we have a couple more
issues paul says you maintain that your
theory of extinction is not discussed
elsewhere but is the phenomena of
natural loss of plant genetic diversity
recognized by other theorists
and he continues as given that it is
recognized by others just looked it up
why do you think that if no one else has
put the pieces together and proposed
this as a mechanism for extinction
okay good question i think i'll give you
my peace of mind on that i'll tell you
why
and this is the reason
no one on planet earth
follows or ever followed the scientific
method
okay the scientific method started at
the beginning of this century
now i'm not posting here i'm not
bragging that's not my point my point is
i'm stating a fact we have a different
scientific method okay in this channel
okay and that's the one we're going to
follow and we say that's the correct
scientific method it's the rational
scientific method and why because
for the first time we're going to
explain causes
we're going to explain mechanisms in
physics right primarily
and so
what these people never did was explain
uh
maybe we did here and there but
if it was it was by luck because the
purpose of the current scientific method
so-called scientific method we call it
the mathematical method is
just to describe make predictions do
experiments and
gain you know win prizes that's what
it's all about it's it's to certify and
win prizes to certify authority okay
and so science is not uh equal to
observation prediction experiment
evidence persuading convincing winning
prizes in authority which is what we
have today that's not science that's not
the scientific method what is science
rational explanations okay so we have a
new paradigm shift
and until you understand that you're you
didn't understand what this channel is
about okay
paleontology what is it explaining the
mechanisms of extinction paleontology is
not going out there in the field dusting
some bones assembling them and giving
them some fancy name and getting you
know
uh
some prize or charging
people so that they can go to a museum
and see your whatever you assemble there
that's not that's not paleontology
paleontology is one thing and one thing
only and it's
explaining the people what caused the
extinction of animals
once we're done with that we're done
with paleontology nobody wants to hear
about paleontology again all we need is
the mechanism how did animals in the
past died and today we don't have a
single rational theory out there for how
the animals in the past died we have the
most popular one the asteroid theory
that says an asteroid hit the earth 65
million years ago and killed all the
dinosaurs
and again it's an irrational theory
from many angles i've covered that in
the past but just summarizing um you
know you have to use different
mechanisms to kill animals in different
habitats and around the world
okay and then the big problem there is
that you cannot explain selectivity why
the mammals and the
angiosperms continued and why the
conifers and the dinosaurs died
and they cannot explain that with the
asteroid asteroid does not have the
ability to distinguish
uh between one animal and the other and
even worse
an asteroid has no way of distinguishing
chronological
chronologically
what died were the old animals and
plants what survived were the young
animals and plants
asteroid does not know the difference
between young and old so not only
between animals like mammals and
dinosaurs or plants like conifers and
angiosperms but it cannot distinguish
between past and present
and that's what has not been answered
okay so that's the point and as a result
the scientists of today look for
evidence
that's why they're looking for evidence
and they purport to extract some from
observations and experiments
that's the problem
in science we don't do experiments in
science we explain them
so the results are why why it happened
that way so in science what you got to
do is
lay back drink a couple beers and
visualize the mechanism so that you can
explain it to someone that's what
science is about but going out there and
collecting data and doing running
experiments without understanding
anything you say oh i collected a lot of
data okay did you make sense of it oh no
but i did the experiment so i'm a
scientist and i did observe so i'm a
scientist and here's all the data and so
i'm a scientist and here's the equation
that i got from all the data and i'm a
scientist
now you're not a scientist until you can
explain the cause the mechanism
okay so
that's why they haven't figured this out
and we ended up with technology and
irrational explanations and no
understanding of the underlying causes
and mechanisms okay so that's my two
cents worse worse
worth on that and so you just take it
for what you want
okay
so let's continue with
uh
physics proper
today we're going to be talking about
velocity
okay and we're going to start it with
a comment that a couple people made okay
and it goes like this
see if i can get it here
there it is uh
paul says
uh referring to me right uh so this is
how we start this
investigation okay tries to debunk
physics and doesn't even know that
velocity and speed are different things
uh-huh you can have an object with
constant speed but changing velocity the
vector part changes in other words
direction not magnitude
okay so he's saying that uh you can have
a change in velocity without changing
speed what you're changing is the
direction of whatever object you're
analyzing okay that's what he's saying
okay and he gives an example see uniform
circular motion this dude wouldn't even
pass high school physics test
okay uh i got to go back to high school
i guess okay
and another fellow that doubles up on
that and he says i just woke from a very
long sleeping that was the best laugh
i'll have all day i'm sure of it we need
you here
so these two fellows i guess went to the
same monastery and uh bless their hearts
i mean poor folks they you know the
first day they they go to
to the monastery you know the uh
uh
priests there have their way with them i
guess because you know all they do is
memorize and just spit out what they
memorized and so this fellow is
convinced that you can change
the velocity okay by just changing the
direction where did he get that well he
just memorized it in uh
in
school you know the monastery uh that's
what they taught him and he just repeats
it you know he marked d on the scantron
sheet because that's how he got a
hundred and he said oh i'm a genius
you know a lot of ram but very little
cpu you know
didn't use it at all
okay so let's find out what's wrong with
this okay uh there's there's something
wrong there okay let's find out what it
is
here we have give me a second here
been coughing and uh sneezing all these
days i don't feel bad but it's like you
know uh it doesn't go away
okay and so here it is um
uh it's a comment made by the second
fella and he says the font he says a
theory in science is carefully thought
out
is a carefully thought out explanation
yeah that's what a theory is
theory is an explanation carefully
thought out we're going to call it
rational
if it's a rational explanation that's
what a theory is and that's what science
does it rationally explains good
we're done okay
but then he continues his definition of
science
[Laughter]
the intellectual and practical activity
encompassing the systematic study
study you study okay of the structure
and behavior of the physical and natural
world through what observation and
experiment
well you know you can do all the
experiments you want you can observe all
you want you can study all you want it
doesn't mean that you're going to be
able to
explain rationally
okay in fact we have that situation
today where you have uh quantum
mechanics says a particle can be in two
places at once uh then you have mr
feinman he says he nobody understands
quantum mechanics you have general
relativity he says well black holes you
got a zero dimensional singularity that
pulls on a star billions of miles away
you know they're all irrational
explanations you cannot imagine any of
that stuff
or mass pulling on you know in the case
of dark matter mass a concept pulling
all the stars together uh towards the
center of the galaxy
you know these are all irrational
explanations and so there it's
non-segregator uh you know the it
doesn't follow that if a theory is in
science is a rational explanation none
of this that he mentioned there the
definition of science matches that at
all okay
and just in case uh here we have uh
his uh
notion of the steps that we have to
follow in the scientific method this is
all the blue ones are stuff that he
put out there he just copied and pasted
again he's just memorizing uh using a
lot of ram and no cpu here he says make
an observation okay i guess uh you see
you
look but you don't see that's great uh
you ask a question oh great
okay why is there something rather than
nothing is that the type of question
they ask in at the monastery
and then you do a test and experiment
you experiment your hypothesis okay so i
guess uh you do some kind of lab
experiment to see if you can produce
god you know because your hypothesis is
that god made the universe so you're
going to do some kind of experiment to
prove your hypothesis i guess you
collect data
in a trash can i guess deliver it
somewhere and then you examine the
results and draw conclusions yeah again
non-sequitur because um
none of this matches
or or in any way
gives you rational explanations
if you follow all these steps it doesn't
mean you're going to conclude with a
rash with a rational explanation that's
the issue here okay
so yeah this is not the
uh
scientific method but that's when
everybody's been following now for
at least 400 years since the 17th
century revolution they think it's all
about experiments and math in fact
physics uh
is said to be you know math is said to
be the language of physics you'll hear
that many places just look it up and
they say also math is the language of
science so
you know
you got math and experiments that's it
that's what they think science is but
see math and experiments does not give
you a rational explanation of how
mother nature runs her shop
and as well like he said at the
beginning uh theory is exactly that
explaining rationally
okay so there is a contradiction between
the scientific method and science his
definition of science that he obviously
copied from the monastery and
uh the definition of what a theory is
which is an explanation okay and that's
what science is theorizing
okay we have to explain some sometimes
somewhere we have to explain how this
universe works
okay so uh where's the problem
well the problem really starts again
first with the scientific method
but
in
in the context of physics where did we
go wrong
well we went wrong when the
mathematicians took over or maybe better
yet said they never released
or relinquished uh their math
and so it was the mathematicians who
continued with the long line of
so-called researchers and scientists
since the days of the greeks
so it was always
along the path of mathematics it was
always the mathematicians who led the
way
lead the way fearless leader you know
and so the fearless leaders were all
mathematicians
and so they thought they were going to
be able to explain the workings of this
universe by running experiments and
doing math you know creating their
equations they were looking for the
equation that would give them uh
an understanding of how this universe
works
but see an equation can only give you a
description it cannot give you an
explanation there is no equation on
planet earth no math on planet earth
that can tell you what the mechanism is
okay if i want to know how a window
broke i don't use math i say a rock went
through the window if i want to know why
the box went up i i don't use equations
what i say is i pull down the rope that
was around the pulley and i pulled the
box up
that's physics the other one is math
so math will not give you an explanation
of the causes and mechanisms that's the
issue okay
so
because the mathematicians took over
okay because they were the ones who led
the way fearless leader you know
uh
they never cared about objects
they never cared about house they don't
use objects even to this day
they move concepts around they talk
about force they talk about waves they
talk about plasma electricity and they
move these things they move the
electricity from here to there they move
the mass they transfer the energy
they're transferring and moving concepts
so they had no use for objects even to
this day they don't use objects
and we stopped using objects
specifically in the 1920s the roaring
20s that's when quantum
you know
took power
and left behind any notion that we can
understand this
the workings of the universe from a
mechanistic point of view
so they never used objects and because
they never used objects they never
defined the keyword object they never
realized that you cannot explain a
mechanism
without an object
if you don't have objects in the
universe what the hell are you going to
explain what what is happening if there
are no objects
so you need objects as a foundation of
physics and if you need objects the
first word you have to define in physics
is the word object okay so they never
defined the word object and because of
that they never defined the word concept
and so they they to this day they don't
know the difference between or
understand the difference between an
object and a concept
that's where you have to start okay and
you'll see where this leads
okay so here's the
scientific definition of the word object
it's not that which we can touch or see
because we can't see or touch the table
on the other side of the universe that's
in the land of the klingons does that
mean that's table's not an object
okay
i mean you don't have to go that far you
can talk about the table that a china
man has on the other side
of the earth and you know you can't see
or touch uh the table that they have in
shanghai okay
so uh does that mean that table is not
an object
does the word table represent always an
object
and the answer is yes table is a table
as a table and so the golden principle
of physics physics requires an object
you can't do physics without an object
what is an object it's not that which
you can see or touch it's that which has
shape the only universal property
all objects have this property
is shape form okay so that's our
starting point
uh
in contrast to this we have the word
concept what is a concept well here you
see it concept uh if you look it up uh
dictionary.com wikipedia that says
concept a general notion or idea what's
a notion a conception or idea what's an
idea conception or notion
100 uh circular 360 degrees uh wikipedia
no different ideas or notions what's a
notion concept what's an idea an
abstract concept
no we have to define these words in such
a way that we don't use synonyms okay
and so what is a concept a word that
invokes or embodies two objects okay so
first you need to define the word object
before you define the word concept and a
concept is founded on the word object
you need two objects to
have a concept okay
that's the difference between object and
concept uh the quick way of
of determining this is by saying that um
a concept does not have shape that's a
good way of
uh separating objects from concepts but
the important thing is that
every word in the dictionary falls
either under object or under concept
there is no third category either it has
shape and represents an object it
doesn't have shape it represents a
concept
that's that's the quick rule of thumb
okay
so
as long as you got that there you won't
get hurt okay
we got that okay so let's find out here
we have uh an object or a concept you
you got to figure out if if this is an
object or a concept here we have god
it's got an object or a concept i mean
what do you pray to do you pray to an
object the guy who uh fellow
i guess anthropomorphic being that
created adam and eve and all of us or do
you pray to all these concepts there
love and spirit and
god is good you know intelligence is is
that what god is
i mean uh is god a concept or an object
does god have shape or is he just an
abstract concept that is a relation
between two objects
okay
and um
we continue here and find out how about
space time here space time is space-time
an object or a concept is space-time a
uh this thingy that prevents the earth
from flying out of the solar system that
comes up against the skin of our planet
or is it just a pair of coordinates uh
time space time there coordinates on the
right
what is what is space time is it an
abstract concept or is a physical object
because if we're going to explain how
this universe works especially gravity
hopefully it's a physical object and you
can't switch it around say well no um
let me show you the coordinates
and here's another one velocity
um
what is velocity is velocity an object
or a concept
say bill are you kidding me of course
it's a concept in fact it's a dynamic
concept velocity has to do with
something along with speed how fast
something is moving
well uh
is it possible that somehow
all these people confused uh velocity
for an object all these mathematicians
okay
uh i'm gonna argue today that maybe
that's exactly the case that maybe what
they did was think that they were
dealing with an object or or turned it
into an object without even realizing it
velocity yeah you can kick velocity you
can hold it in your hands throw it up
velocity is a ball
you say you're crazy bro
what do you mean
yeah according to mathematics uh
velocity is a ball okay that's going to
be the argument
okay so uh here we have
a comparison of velocity versus speed
okay
and what do we have there well if if
you can see that i put a smiley face
he's not smiling very much he's an angry
smiley
and i had to put that face in there
because see velocity has to have
direction
okay if if you don't put that face there
well all you have is speed
you have a ball a blank ball is speed
but a ball that has
a face on it is facing in some
orientation or whatever
then it's velocity otherwise it's just
speed
okay but it turns out that you know
speed is a mathematical concept whereas
direction
is a qualitative concept
direction belongs strictly to physics
there is no concept in mathematics
that is called direction
okay
so what i want to show here is that
somehow
uh this velocity
incorporated speed with an abstract um
qualitative concept called direction
what is a concept
two objects in fact direction
requires two objects you know if god i
can put to god anywhere where he wants
to hide in the in the universe or beyond
the universe god can be in the fourth
fifth tenth dimension for all i care
there should be a direct line of
direction from me to him
if god is there right
he can hide anywhere he wants but i'm
gonna find him with my direction there's
got to be two points for direction okay
and other than that you're going to end
up with a surrealistic notion that oh no
he's in the 10th dimension you can't
point to the 10th dimension you know
yeah you can
yeah you just point upwards like you
know the uh flat landers do
uh
they say well in that direction i can't
see it but i should have a straight line
of direction to god because even if
you're in a flat land you know and uh
you're the three-dimensional guy and you
put a ball on top of the flat lander he
says i can't see it or whatever right
but there should be a straight line of
direction from that ball to the
flatlander where whether he sees it or
not
okay i hope you understood that it
doesn't matter if he can see it or not
it's got nothing to do with that it's
got to do with the fact that whether he
knows it or not there's a straight line
of direction from that ball to the
flatlander
and the same thing with 10th or 20th
dimension i don't care where god wants
to hide
uh i can't see that dimension i can't
feel it
because they don't exist in reality but
assuming they exist i don't care i don't
have to see them or touch them or
imagine them all i know is there's got
to be a straight line of direction
wherever god is to me
that i know for a fact okay
and so uh yeah you need two points to
make a concept and especially the
concept direction you need two objects
okay two reference points okay but again
that's a qualitative concept
and
it belongs to physics where a speed
that belongs to math you know meters
seconds
that's math that doesn't belong in
physics at all
okay
so that's our starting point let's find
out where this takes us
okay uh we start with mr aristotle he
already had an intuitive notion of what
velocity is okay he didn't really zero
in on it but you can see from his
statement i just pulled one at random
but there's a couple more in there if
you want to read aristotle you'll see in
more detail but here's here's uh the one
that i'm going to pick out just to show
you that he had an intuitive notion of
what velocity is
it would be absurd to suppose that the
motion of one in a circle and of another
in a straight line cannot be similar
but that the one must inevitably move
more quickly or more slowly than the
other just as if the course of one were
downhill and of the other uphill
so he had this notion that if you move
in a straight line that's you know
that's uh speed in other words that's
understood okay uh like intuitively you
don't need more than that
but velocity you know if if you have i
don't know uh a group of people and
they're moving in a circle
and they all have to be in a straight
line at all times and arrive at the
starting point all together
well the guy on the outside he's got to
go faster
okay so they realize that that you know
there's this uh angular momentum
you know this uh acceleration going on
he couldn't put his finger on that
because he still didn't have the concept
of uh
velocity versus speed but he realized
there's a difference there and he was
talking about something else anyway so
he went off on a tangent but at least he
sat down that they already had an
intuitive notion of what velocity is
okay and uh it would have to wait until
uh really kepler because uh kepler was a
contemporary of um
galileo
and he went out there and he tried to
figure out the motion of the planets and
he realized that they were not going in
circles that they were going in ellipses
and that's when you know these uh
mathematicians they said well hold it uh
we got to be able to calculate
you know
not only speed
which is more or less straight line
right but what if we turn a corner and
we we start going in circles well how do
you calculate that
and so i explained this the other day
okay uh that
people like
newton and leibniz you know they they
were in they went in there and they
tried to figure out
among others you know then i just
mentioned these two fellows because they
were working primarily on the calculus
and so they started working on
derivatives and calculus and developing
math to a higher level and so they had
to figure out how they were going to
calculate you know velocity
and the difference between velocity and
speed
and yeah eventually they zeroed in on
the fact that it's got direction that's
the difference between velocity and
speed speed is just you know meters per
second the other guy's meters per second
but now we're going to put direction
we're going to change the orientation of
the thing in question the thing that's
moving okay and and they did it because
of planets primarily that's where this
whole notion comes in they they were
studying the planets the motion of the
planets
okay so here we have a curve that i
showed the other day i'll go quickly
through it because i've already gone
through this but i just want to point
out that first they usually what they do
today is calculate the average velocity
of an object and what is that the
position final minus the position
initial and
time final time initial you do the uh
subtraction and the division and you get
the average velocity very
uh kindergarten-ish uh
basic arithmetic okay but now when you
get to instantaneous velocity which is
what velocity truly is
okay
you calculate it for a single point in
time
let me repeat that you calculate it for
let's put it in different words for a
cross section of time it's like you cut
time and only at that point
in time do you have velocity
you do not have velocity across several
seconds you have velocity at a given
cross-section of time so if you have the
timeline
imagine cutting it with the thinnest
sword that you have god's sword so thin
you know
that's going to be velocity at that
point okay so that's important to
understand how do they calculate well
they calculate it using
uh derivatives okay and what they do is
you know you again i explained the other
day as you go to the time
you come inwards to the point that
you're trying to measure and you take
the derivative essentially what it is is
you have a tangent okay what is a
tangent it's a perpendicular to a radius
there you see it okay it's perpendicular
to the radius uh radius of what of a
circle a circle of what well you put a
circle there imaginary circle that
touches a single point on that curve so
you have the curve you the point that
you're going to calculate the velocity
on and that point coincides with a
circle that meets at that point only at
one point okay
and you put a
radius there and you put a perpendicular
which we call the tangent then you move
along the tangent you calculate the
derivative the derivative again you take
the limit of the change in time as it
approaches zero between the delta x and
the
dt
okay and that's how you arrive at a
given point
uh let's see if we can illustrate this
so that i make it plainer for those who
have a little trouble understanding math
okay we're not interested in the math
we're interested in the concept here
okay
so um here it is
here we have uh smiley again he's angry
maybe losing the race or whatever and uh
velocity is is a physical object and
that's that's going to be my argument
right what you have here is you have a
single point and you see the coordinates
there okay so you you have these two
coordinates the x and y typical s and y
and uh you have a single point okay but
notice that uh smiley has a face
because smiley has to have orientation
see if if i don't uh put a face in there
if i leave it like that
well then we don't have um
orientation what we have really is speed
okay so
uh you need to put an orientation to the
point the point has to be oriented in
some direction
that's that's what i'm saying okay
uh if if you just have a blank point
like that without a face you don't know
which direction that dot is pointing and
you say well there's the line and the
graph etc so let's get rid of those so
it doesn't bother you okay
so here we have it
okay here's
smiley smiley without the without any
reference
that's velocity velocity is
no reference really okay all you have is
a single point in time cross section of
time
with orientation with a direction
okay
and again if i don't put a smiley face
on there or any kind of face well i'll
end up with this
i end up with only speed
okay you see what's happening here
we only have speed
because
you know i don't know which direction
that point is pointing now and i don't
have a reference because i got rid of
all the coordinates and all that stuff i
only have a point i want to know what
the speed of that thing is and more than
that i want to know velocity in other
words speed plus orientation plus
direction
and i don't have direction
i only have speed at all if anything but
it turns out i don't have speed because
you know it turns out that uh with
without any reference
without a second point
you know all i have is a dot that's what
i have
and what is a dot is an object
that's all it is all i have is a ball
there
you know without any reference i don't
have speed
and i don't have um
velocity
because to get speed or and specifically
velocity you need a reference point you
need what
two points you need two objects
concept what is a concept two objects a
relationship between two objects here we
have a single object in the universe
what is its speed what is its velocity
in which way is it pointing the only way
i can find out is again if i put a
smiley face on it okay
so this is our starting point again okay
okay so what's the issue the issue is
that
we have this centripetal
centripetal acceleration
the reason uh that dot
does not fly out of the solar system
when
like a planet doesn't fly out of the
solar system is because something is
preventing it from leaving
and you can mimic this with uh like i do
it here you know with a little ball
and you just swing it around okay
at the end of a string
and when you do that well yeah the ball
doesn't fly out of my hand why because
it's being pulled
towards my thumb to to where i'm holding
it
and that's more or less the situation
where the sun and the earth the earth
just goes around because somehow the sun
is retaining it in its orbit
okay no matter what the earth wants to
do
uh the sun keeps
swinging it around itself
for whatever reason we call it gravity
you know if it weren't for gravity it
would fly away okay whatever gravity is
okay so what is that we have centripetal
centripetal acceleration
but the only way you can have
a value for velocity
is if you have also direction
and in order to have direction
you need two points
and
the velocity velocity the instantaneous
velocity is a cross section of time it's
a single point it has no reference
because they've calculated by moving
along that green
um
tangent
and it's a calculated value
so
if you take the smiley face away because
you don't have a reference point
all you have is a dot all you have is a
ball that's all you have in front of you
you don't have a uh
a second point in which to gauge
direction
or even speed
because all concepts require two
objects and what these people have done
is throughout
okay i guess i got reconnected i don't
know what happened there uh that's uh
youtube
trying to censor me i guess
i wrote this okay so the issue here is
that uh
velocity is for a cross section of time
you only have one point you only have
one value
and that value not only contains speed
but it contains the um orientation in
other words direction
and you can't have direction or speed
for that matter unless you have a second
point
okay now you may be able to calculate
the speed at a given velocity at a given
point there
how are you going to calculate direction
without a second point without any a
a reference
that's the issue
and so and then and then you have the
issue that you have this centripetal
what acceleration
so what we were talking about is you
know the fact that light is being curved
okay uh by gravity according to general
relativity it's being curved and they
say well it's got the same speed the
speed has not changed what's changed is
just the
direction
but the direction requires centripetal
acceleration and that takes us back to
what is acceleration and acceleration is
a change in velocity and velocity
includes direction and so it's a
circular argument okay what the
mathematicians did they embodied again
um
a concept a mathematical concept a
quantitative concept such as speed
together with a qualitative concept
which does not belong in mathematics at
all and they put them together because
they like all these dualities you know
they like uh wave packets you know light
is both a particle and a wave
you know what is a point it's both a
location and a dot what is a line it's
both an itinerary and a stick and here
they did the same thing they said they
took velocity and they said what is this
velocity well we're going to take the
stick of direction and we're going to
unite it with the ball of
speed
and
can you put that together and create
something with that well no we calculate
the value because they're not interested
in objects at all they got rid of the
elephant they're doing dealing with the
center of mass or whatever and that's
what they move okay so this is the issue
the issue is that they've uh kind of
united these things into this duality
which
mathematicians are fond of and here um
just want to point out one more thing
there and that's this warp space
uh just so that you're aware this is a
little different than what we're talking
about when we say that we swing a ball
around our heads okay
in this case we've got something
different what you're seeing there is
that
the sun weighs down space time and space
time is pushing on the photon
so the photon is not being drawn to the
sun what it is it's being pushed towards
the sun by the warping of space that's
what they're showing here okay so let's
let's make sure we understand that
because a lot of people don't it's not
like newton said newton thought that the
sun was pulling on the earth somehow by
some magical means that he could not
explain that's not what's happening here
general relativity does not believe in
pull
it believes in push it says look the sun
weighs down it pushes down the canvas
and then what happens there is that you
have the
bending of space-time
forcing compelling the photons because
this is a stream of photons right uh to
curve
okay so this is the explanation that
quan that uh general relativity gives to
gravity
okay so the
all i'm trying to say here is that the
um
the mechanism that uh
of
centripetal acceleration is no longer
you know being pulled by a string by the
sun
okay
assuming this is in this case the photon
one of the photons right it's not being
pulled by the sun okay it's being pushed
from outside because the sun weighs down
space-time creates this wall
and
uh the photons roll around you know the
uh
the curvature
of this space-time thingy
okay so let's summarize see if we got
all the points okay make sure you
understand each one okay what's it
what's acceleration well it's a change
in velocity
okay
and what is velocity speed and direction
important direction because direction is
a qualitative concept speed is math is a
mathematical quantitative parameter
measured for example in meters per
second velocity is also measured in
meters per second that's the math part
but it is not a mathematical
quantitative parameter because of
direction
direction is what a static qualitative
concept
and math has no use for qualitative
concepts you can't put direction in an
equation okay so velocity is a single
point
in space
in time right
that has direction what do we end up
with what we end up with accelerate
uh without changing speed and changes
direction without a reference because
it's a single point
you figure it out okay so uh yeah
they never
were able to show
uh
physically
that
yeah you can change
acceleration without changing speed
they just calculated and says well what
do we put in there well we'll put
uh
orientation in other words direction
but we have a single point so what is
the direction well for that you need a
second point and and so it's a circular
argument because acceleration
is a function of velocity which is a
function of
direction and
speed
okay so this is this is a circular
argument of mathematical physics why
because they never define what an object
is they don't know what a concept is and
worst of all uh they say that physics
that math is the language of physics
and they don't deal with objects and so
they don't even know what they're doing
anymore all they do is calculate and
yeah for calculation it's great but then
you can't bring that into physics
because you cannot put in real terms
you cannot make a movie of velocity
because you can't even
put velocity in a single frame of the
movie and why can't you because it's a
single point
and if you don't put that smiley face in
there you don't know which direction
that smiley is pointing but even if you
have that uh how did you figure out
which way to put his face is he pointing
upwards or to the side well you won't
know until you have a second point and
you don't have that second point in the
frame of your film
okay
food for thought
okay let's continue here with uh some of
the questions that people made since
last time a couple of them i covered
most of them anyways today but yeah foul
says definition of definition a
statement of the exact meaning of a word
especially in a dictionary okay
uh pseudo science a collection of
beliefs or practices mistakenly regarded
as being based on scientific method okay
making claim to be both scientific and
factual but are incompatible with the
scientific method okay
and i like the next thing they say these
aren't my definition i don't write
dictionaries and such i just use them
what this all did you went to the
dictionary opened up you just copied it
you know copy and paste uh it's what
they do with the monasteries you know
you go there and you have these
authoritative
figures you know the priests the bishops
and they impressed these kids
uh quite a bit you know the first day uh
who knows what they do to them you know
but the kids stand in all the
bishop or the priest or whoever the
cardinal and and so from then on all
they do is what use ram and no cpu all
they do is memorize and be able to count
beads on the rosary and repeat you know
what they learned by rote
okay so let's define uh
this a little better let's see if we can
improve on this okay here it is
definition this is a scientific
definition limitation placed on the
extent or usage of a word
that's what a scientific definition is
definition is not the same as meaning as
this fellow copied there now a
definition is what a prosecutor proposes
meaning is what the juror gets out of it
meaning has to do with how a definition
is interpreted by the receiving end of
course right if a definition is on the
emitting end the meaning is on the
receiving end a prosecutor issues
definitions a juror infers
meaning
okay
so i hope uh
you can see the differences there
between what this fellow copied from
some dictionary in the monastery and
what people who
challenge those definitions
um proposing in exchange now you got to
do some cpu you can't do ram okay in
science uh ram is
for religion for for church that's what
you do in sunday school so we don't copy
and paste
we think and we challenge
that's science
well
part of science you got to propose also
but challenging is a good first step you
want to be skeptical of what you read
and if you don't like it well then
something
is troubling you about it and if
something is traveling in your body you
got to reason it out and once you reason
that out you have to have be able to
explain it to someone so that you can
say look this is irrational let me give
you the rational version
that's the way it works and then the
other guy has to you know
uh introduce a rejoinder or whatever you
know he's got to challenge your version
and if he can't well yours sticks until
somebody can
that's the way it works in science but
copy paste
and say well everybody on earth uses it
all the dictionaries have it yeah that
that doesn't count in science that
counts in religion
paul says here
uh if i can get this here uh do you have
any takes about intelligence do you
believe that the iq measures are
accurate
uh the answer is no to that
i don't in fact i talked about that i'll
get there in a second if there is an
smartest race it would be east asians
their brain mass and skull size being
bigger as well as iq uh i don't think
it's a question of size they say that
when they measure the
cavity inside the head of a neanderthal
they had just about as big as brain as
ours apparently in some cases a little
even bigger and does that mean the
neanderthals had the same intelligence
that we have in other words
did they have the
all the stuff that uh we have in our
brains today with all so many concepts
and things that we've invented well no
uh maybe they had the ability maybe that
they had the potential it doesn't mean
that they uh
actually use that
cavity for anything more than hunting
so uh does size matter
uh maybe for sex but but not for for not
for it not necessarily okay the yeah
developed brain is typically bigger but
there's more criteria than that it's
it's the quality of what's going on
there with the electromagnetic fields
the chemical
reactions in there in the brain
if there's a
well okay the guy says that east asians
okay there aren't many accurate tests
for intelligence and there are many
types of intelligence reasoning etcetera
etcetera okay
this is my take on intelligence i did
talk about that a long time ago okay but
here it is
um
you can find it in uh in that link there
if you go there you'll find my uh
my notions of what intelligence is but
here are the three main points uh people
confuse brain with mind
brain belongs to physics mind is you
know more abstract okay
it's what brain produces through
chemical reactions etc but people
confuse the brain size etc like this
i'll just mention uh with mind with what
the brain does
and then only
one champion of speed
one champion of size strength and
there's only one champion of
intelligence you know i think the king
of speed as i point out in my article
there uh is the cheetah and i think the
cheetah probably was the fastest animal
on land ever i think a cheetah would
outrun a dinosaur or some of these other
even though they were bigger
i don't know
i think the cheetah would do pretty well
against some of these animals
my take is that cheat is probably one of
the fastest animals
ever
in fact i think it is the fastest animal
that ever had but for sure the cheetah
today i think is the fastest animal
uh on earth
uh gazelle
gives them a run for their money but
the only reason though gazelle escapes
is because it it zigzags but the cheetah
is is pretty good you know catching us
else anyways uh there's only one king of
speed and there's probably one king of
size i guess on land would be the
elephant and uh in the ocean or probably
forever was the whale okay
and so on so
you know those are the kings and there
only can be one king of brain and we're
the king of brains
okay
and
you know we've got probably the biggest
ratio of brain
size
uh to body
okay so in that sense we're the king
okay but as i say all species develop
they brain
and think there is there is not a single
uh animal on earth that does not have a
brain there is not a single animal that
does not think
and uh
you'll deduce that from the cell
every animal is made of cells and the
cell is a compartmentalized entity
it's the first living entity and there
you see why it's a very complex entity
and it's got its cpu central processing
unit it's got
its organization in there that's already
a not only the first living entity that
can move against gravity but it's the
first one that processes information if
it's going to control each one of these
compartments
okay so that's essentially in a nutshell
what i wrote so you can look up that
link there
and you'll
come up to speed on my argument on
intelligent and there are a couple more
articles there in that list so you can
look those up as well
okay um here we go with another question
uh uh issue that someone made
uh if i can get it up there uh here it
is
paul says
are electricians mathematicians
mathematicians
or rational scientists
well uh
in order to be a rational scientist you
have to explain in a rational manner
what does that mean well it means that
you're not going to move concepts around
that's the main one if you move a
concept you're an irrational individual
that's okay if you want to do poetry
or maybe if you want to summarize
arguments i guess you can say you're
closing arguments and you want to use a
little
you know poetry in there
uh figures of speech or whatever that's
okay but when you're explaining the
mechanism it's got to be straightforward
it's got to be objective okay and so if
an electrician
explains something in a rational manner
without moving concepts
and with with justifying his uh atoms
for example electricians want to explain
electricity just an example
he can't use the quantum atom
because we're going to object to that
immediately he's going to have to
explain why that little electron bead
rolls around
forever around the nucleus without
leaving or falling to the nucleus
if he cannot explain that he doesn't
have a model to start out with
and his presentation is is dead we
remove the microphone from his mouth
the only way he can give his
presentation is if he can justify his
atom to begin with he's got to show his
atom first then he can talk about the
little bead moving from adam to adam and
that's electricity for example this is
just an example
okay if he can't do that if he can't
present an atom
uh he's got nothing to
instruct us he's got nothing to teach us
okay
okay with that i'll see you folks next
time